okay so let's start getting our hands
dirty in creating our customer facing
marketing materials step one is to
create our landing page from a marketing
perspective a landing page is a
standalone web page that in the
beginning can serve as our website it
has a specific objective and usually
limited options for visitors in the
early stages of your business you might
want to use just a landing page rather
than a full website to generate interest
in your product and collect contact
information from potential users before
you put a lot of efforts in a full
website this is when we really get to
figure out and test our messaging we can
track the reaction and behavior of
people to our messaging sometimes by
having two or three different versions
and running an a/b test we'll talk more
about a be testing in less than five one
of the cool things about your landing
page is that it can help you validate
your idea you can build up links to
potential features and depending on the
number of clicks it gets you can decide
if that feature is worth investing
resources in developing on abarkment if
we edit a link to cat-sitting
and no one clicked on it we would know
not to build out this picture given that
we're a startup with a limited team and
budget this method can be game-changing
some startups would prefer to launch the
landing page before their product is
even viable so they can measure traffic
or start collecting email addresses of
interested users once we have a basic
product or MVP Minimum Viable Product
you can use your landing page to measure
conversions there are nice free tools
out there to simply build your own
landing page we as the envision for a
refresher of how to use envision well
back to our prototyping course when
thinking about creating your landing
page you should answer a few questions
for your customers let's cover those now